welcome ladies and gentlemen to another
episode of riffing with Griffin this is
episode eight our special Christmas
episode little early Christmas gift and
I'm here for you and with another
special theme song I don't know lot
about Christmas but there's just one
thing
I don't need no presents coming near
that Christmas tree I just want a
podcast of my own
more than you can ever know
[Music]
i'ma make your wish come true
[Music]
cuz all I'm using Christmassy his red
very graphic
yeah Merry Christmas y'all all I need is
15 with Griffin riffle Griffin is good
turn on that block cats now don't you
wish you could cuz all I want for
Christmas is there a Griffin hey I mean
I know I'm a damn fool but Merry
Christmas everybody I got my Christmas
sweater on I'm giving you an early gift
this is Griffin with Griffin episode 8
and thank you everybody that has been
subscribing and writing comments and
I've gotten even gotten theme songs
people have sent me it's just been a
tremendous ride I'm glad you guys are on
the journey with me and we'll just see
where it goes right I'm having a good
time doing this and I just I appreciate
everybody that is sending me love
alright so today's episode episode rate
over from a Griffin episode 7 I told you
I was gonna do this so today we're gonna
be talking about three things but the
main thing is I'm gonna talk to you
about how to be a stand-up comedian what
you should do I'm just give you my
thoughts about stand-up comedy that's
why I'm standing up right now so I can
give you that stand-up comedy energy and
you know so that's what the main core of
the episode is gonna be about and I keep
telling you I like doing these different
segments I've only done one real segment
but this is another one it's called what
you need to do and this goes out to
Google I was on the phone with my mom
who is over 70 and I'm on the phone with
her for like two hours trying to explain
to her how to work her Google Gmail her
Gmail she can't figure it out like she
say she gets like a hundred messages
right and then the screen only shows 25
messages at a time so she doesn't check
our emails all the messages get pushed
down to the next page and she can't
figure out how to get to the next page
and when you look at the Google homepage
the mother [ __ ] is complicated it's
too complicated like you got to have a
freaking degree at the Learning Annex to
figure out how to send and receive
email if you haven't if you're not
computer savvy at all they think you're
helping you out with all these options
and tabs and categories and all this
nonsense hey Google make the [ __ ] easy
for people that are not computer savvy
okay you think you're helping with all
that [ __ ] but you're not because I'm
on the phone with my mom for two hours
and she still can't figure this [ __ ] out
so that was a little quickie of what you
need to do that's for Google all right
next is before I talk about being a
stand-up comedian is I saw the movie
Creed 2 and I want to talk about it
Creed 2 review um I don't want to just
completely trash the movie cuz like I've
been on shows I've been on things and I
hate when critics just bash you so on
let me try to be respectful as I can but
I'm not a fan of this movie spoiler
alert if you haven't seen Creed 2 go
watch it I mean the first Creed
I enjoyed because how Michael P Jordan
acts he is just his angst that he had in
the movie I think it lent itself to that
story this guy trying to like live in
his father's footsteps and you know his
father who was a legend and he's trying
to build his own weight but I just don't
think it worked in Creed to a couple
things I didn't like about Creed - first
of all I love how they bought Drago back
right but then when you hear Drago's
story you're like damn you know he lost
everything he was the villain in the
first one okay he was the villain and
now he has this son who he's trained in
the box but he lost everything his wife
left him
everybody abandoned him so now he's like
a scourge of society so now he's raising
his son for you know for revenge and his
son works in a cement factory or
whatever and he's got to go out and
brawl fight and he's like really dingy
fighting places and but what does it
happen is you feel for this character
you feel for the son like you know baby
Drago is not the villain in this movie
to me he was the hero he's got this
abusive father and his mother literally
left him his mom his deadbeat mom left
him his father's cruel and abusive and
and pushing him to the point of like
where you don't even know what the
purpose of this is in anymore and then
you know they have this
right and then you you I literally was
like well I want Drago to win I thought
he was more sympathetic character now
some people out there would be like well
this is good they did it differently it
only would have been different if Creed
would have lost cuz here you had this
guy he's this spoiled you know he his
wife
it is R&B singer she's got a contract
his mom is in a great mansion he's got
this great legacy the Creed legacy you
know he wasn't a sympathetic character I
did not like him at all in comparison to
this other guy the fact that you know
Creed wins in the end I just was like I
don't like this I just did not like that
at all and then and then to top it all
off to top it all off why did they make
their baby deaf cuz in the movie
Tessa Thompson plays a character where
she's got she's got bad hearings so she
finally has a baby with Creed and then
like they're worried it just kids gonna
die here and then they made it in the
movie that the baby's death
what give us a win man like this was
unnecessary drama so much client in this
movie in like like unbelievable angst
and drama for no reason at all you know
you want to you want to come back story
you want you know Creed beats him up I
think it'll been better if the young
young Drago I mean Drago I mean if he
was like like a villainous type
character but you felt for him you were
like damn this kid grew up horrible his
mom left him his dad's an [ __ ] and
now he's got to get beat up by this
American like his father got beat up
what's the point in that
anyways we're from a Griffin gives creed
to uh yeah I gave it a you know I wasn't
a fan have a fighter UFC fighter friend
my buddy Eric Koch who we're on worst
fire team ever together if you like
video games you want to watch some
people play video games check out where
his fire team that's my other podcast
I'm on but Eric's a fighter so he's all
like I loved it I loved the fighting in
the training and it was realistic and I
was like no bro this like all the story
stuff just did not grab me but anyways
I'm actually have him on it we'll talk
about it some more but so that's my
second segment talking about a Creed - I
wasn't a fan of it but you know
there's some entertaining points so I'm
just not gonna completely trashed a
movie but there you go
so we got what you need to do and
there's my movie review so now the point
of today's podcast is all those people
out there who have been sending me
messages about hey I want to be a
comedian
I want to do comedy or I've always
wanted to do it so let's talk about
becoming a comic and what I believe you
should do and just talk a little finer
points about stand-up comedy you know
when I hide the reason why I wanted to
be a comic was because I just I just was
enough I just felt funny like I would
say things to people when even when I
was in like good fifth grade and people
would laugh at what I was saying and you
know then you you know you you grow up
and you're like oh you actually can make
a living you know being funny or you
know and I remember when I was a
basketball coach I used to yell at the
kids and the way I would yell on the way
I would be passionate about what I was
talking about the crowd would be
laughing so you know I'm putting on a
show and I'm like yo I'm really upset
why the hell y'all laughing and it comes
to find out that like just it's just I'm
just a funny dude like that and so I got
into stand-up comedy so look if you're
thinking about it and you've been
sitting on you ask you like what do I do
longer you're scared or nervous there's
really nothing to be nervous about one
thing I would suggest is if there's some
stand-up comedy class in your area and
you've never done any kind of
performance art I would suggest that you
go take a class to take one class
because it's a comfortable environment
and you have other like-minded people
who are nervous about public speaking
which is still like well I think the
number one fear in America is public
speaking even over death so take a class
about public speaking and communications
or something so you can you know get
past that fear and a class will help you
get past that fear because it's a
comfortable environment all right the
next thing I would suggest to is like
just start writing like start writing
what you think is funny because
ultimately that's what stand-up comedy
is is retelling something that you think
is funny and a joke
the construction of the joke is
explaining why you think something is
funny that's to setup punchline you know
everything that comes after that how you
explain stuff is like you know that's
the important part of stand-up comedy is
like
you know like when you hear somebody
retell a story I say somebody tells a
story and they're like um oh you know
you had to be there you know when
somebody says you had to be there that
tells me that they are a horrible
storyteller because why something is
funny or what are you talking about like
these are important concepts so like you
know when you are like retelling
somebody a story you have to setup what
the story is about where you were who
was there the circumstances because all
those things will put people in the
mindset of like oh I get why this is
funny because that's what you really
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get the crowd to relate to why
you think something is funny why do you
think it's funny
so understanding why something is funny
is very important because if you
understand why it's funny and you
understand what you're talking about
that's gonna lend itself to
understanding your own personal point of
view so I definitely suggest that you
just start writing so you can like see
like this is what I think is funny
because then you got to start explaining
why you think it's funny I mean that is
really like you know there's no right or
wrong way you know let's just kill there
- there's no right or wrong way to do
comedy there's just like subjective
feelings about it like somebody might go
up and you'd be like what this guy
doesn't have a funny bone in his body
and I just never laughed one time it
doesn't mean that what they're doing is
wrong might not even be your cup of tea
but that's just what happens you know so
you know knowing yourself that's the
first thing like why do people laugh at
you like for me I'm just a funny looking
guy and I'm passionate about things that
maybe I shouldn't be passionate about
and I just have a way of talking about
things and then so people are like oh my
god that's funny now is it what I was
saying
it made it funny or was it how I was
saying it it made it funny this
different styles there - you got
somebody like Seinfeld who he's a
wordsmith he knows exactly what words
he's gonna say he constructs a sentence
a certain way that after he says I send
it you go all man that was funny what he
just said and maybe you're laughing
because you appreciate the effort that
he put into this sentence now there's
other people that you go oh what that
guy did was funny how he said it was
funny
so you have like extremes if you had
like a if you have like a balance bar
one of those one of those you know like
where are you on the scale are you more
this way are you more that way are you
more how you say it are you more what
you say sometimes people want to have a
balance of that it just depends because
not everybody's good at say acting
things out you know so you really gotta
like figure out what's your style you
know
so understanding I always go back to
understanding why something is funny and
understanding what you're actually
talking about is very important like if
I was gonna construct a joke about my
cousin who don't got a job and just got
a dog what is this joke about now it's a
joke gonna be about how my cousin makes
bad decisions and then I'm gonna go on
to talk about you know his my cousin's
dating life and my cousins like how they
he don't pay bills or is it joke about
dogs has a joke about like how a dog can
change you know make you feel like the
world is okay I mean it it could go
wherever you want it to go so
understanding that point of view of like
why something like what you're talking
about to lend itself to be like why is
this thing funny so that's just very
important I think
what did joke is about I think a lot of
comics just Donnell did they know I
think they don't know what they're
talking about and in the correlation of
like why is funny I mean sometimes you
just you just have a disconnect but like
something you're doing there's an
essence of who you are and the crowd is
laughing at that moment so you maybe
sometimes you think oh is because of
this joke but you know if you
intellectualize it and you go like why
are they laughing are they laughing
because of what I look like or like are
they commiserating with what I'm saying
so another thing with that is how you
feel about something that's another
thing that dictates like why people
laugh you know if I'm talking about
something and I'm sad about it then you
could feel that are you laughing about
how sad I am at something that maybe
it's not supposed to be sad so it's like
a misdirection or are you like a lot of
times comics they're angry about
something you know they're angry about
the TSA at the airport let me tell you
what happened at Atia
say you know then they just had this
whole thing and then the crowds laughing
because they're like oh yeah I I that
happens to me too
or they're laughing because they're like
wow this guy really is upset so there's
a lot of different reasons it's very
layered why people laugh at you and
trying to figure out and understand who
you are and how you can express things
will determine what kind of comic you
want to be so just keep writing and
writing until you can see the patterns
forming you know like your brain works
like it's just like music like if you
ever like hear a Pharrell be like you
know Neptune's like you can hear it like
you hear a song and you go oh that's a
Neptune's because they have a certain
rhythm they have a certain style they
have their own spank they put on it your
point of view is gonna be your stank and
then people are gonna kind of be like oh
I can't wait to hear what this guy has
to say about or this girl has to say
about whatever it is they're talking
about so that's you understanding your
point of view so you got to try to get
there but you can only get there by
really looking at your jokes a lot of
problems people have as a comic as they
they don't know how to they don't know
how to move forward like you might have
a premise and you don't know how to move
forward from that premise and I always
say move backwards you already know you
know why this is funny to you make your
setup explaining why you think is this
funny it could be short simple words
short simple sentences like you know
it's like I used to have this joke about
like doesn't I don't like being a
designated driver this is a good example
of another reason this is a good example
of like why you know people interpret
things however they want to so like I
usually had this joke I say I don't like
being a designated driver because it's
like taking care of autistic kids by the
end of the night now there are people
who are involved with autistic kids or
who have an autistic kid and they hear
that joke and they think I'm being
disparaging up just about autistic kids
I'm tunc of some [ __ ] about autistic
kids and I'm saying literally like do
you know how it is to be with autistic
kids that is how it can be when people
are drunk they look very similar you
know yeah you know as you explained it
like that and you talk about it you
might be like well maybe you shouldn't
joke about that but know within the
moment within the split-second of like
how you're supposed to take that it's
not supposed to be you know some you
know jab but that's some one of the
things you're gonna have to worry about
it's like interpreting like I don't know
if that was a good joke or not I don't
you know you just you just have to make
that choice you have to decide like this
is the kind of stuff I want to talk
about and you have to own it like I
really like if whatever you say don't
apologize for it like don't apologize
for it on stage especially because the
crowd will feel that if you want stage
and you're like apologizing for singling
anything really mean does the same is
their gonna feel that and then they're
gonna say yeah you shouldn't be saying
that you got to go up there you gotta
say it you gotta own it just own
whatever you have to say cuz people will
respect you for that and that respect
will be translated into laughter so what
your jokes were about why is it funny
and how are you emotionally connected to
it
these are just some of the techniques
that you have to think about when you
sit down and you say ah I need to write
some jokes you know you got and I
suggest you look at comedy too like
watch comedy and really analyze it and
be like why is what that person said
funny to me you know it's like it's not
some abstract thing you know it's like
when you listen to music you know you
there's melodies and there's bars and
there's like you know there's a chorus
and you know there's a certain format
that you two jokes have just
fundamentally you know you have you set
up your punchline you callbacks your
tags you know you could be a comic like
that or you could be somebody that does
one-liners or you could be somebody
that's like I'm gonna do abrasive comedy
or I want to do slapstick comedy I want
to do cerebral comedy whatever you
decide that's gonna be find a comic that
does that same kind of style and just
watch that formula unfold and ask
yourself Oh what are they talking about
right now
you know don't be confused only at buzz
words don't let buzz words make you feel
like now I can't say this because I said
this word this taboo word and now the
whole joke becomes about that but you
know that's just a whole other
discussion because that's just like why
people are really sensitive but you
can't worry
people being sensitive you just got to
keep on the path so right right a lot
keep riding even if you think it's dumb
eventually if you could start getting
stage time you're gonna write on stage
and you're gonna go up with a concept
okay you know what right now I want to
talk about voting right now I have jokes
while I'm talking about voting I'm
talking about the voting process how I'm
not I wasn't really prepared for voting
I was I didn't know this stuff that the
pamphlets came and I had read all these
things and I was like I don't know who
these judges are so it was like I'm
doing I'm trying to talk about I'm
trying to develop it into a point of
like this is how I feel about this and
am I trying to give a message about
voting like underneath what I'm talking
about am i getting on the crowd because
I feel like voting is people aren't
really informed about voting and I'm
trying to show them hey none of you
[ __ ] are informed you know is that my
message and is that funny you know so as
I'm going through the process you go
through this trial and error but you're
gonna say things and you're gonna be
like mmm okay I don't know that part
worked and that's why you have to
perform perform perform record your
performance performances make sure you
try to record if it's just a voice
recording seat and listen to it listen
back to it and that's gonna be hard cuz
a lot of people don't like hearing their
own voice but you got to go back and
listen to it so you can be like oh I
didn't say that word right or maybe I
should have paused there and then you'll
start to analyze like right now we're
intellectualizing stand up we're talking
about it and he's like you know why is
it funny what are you talking about
what's your point of view when you
actually do it you got to forget about
all this and just naturally just do it
comes natural with practice you're gonna
start to hone in what your technique is
so but definitely you got to start with
riding hey I think this is funny cuz at
first when you first start writing jokes
it's gonna be hacky it's gonna you're
gonna think you're brilliant you know
you're gonna think like you know oh man
no one's ever thought of this no but
trust me whatever you're thinking of
people have thought of it someone's
already done it so you have to put your
own spank on it what do you feel about
this particular subject and it's hard
and like you know you got like
is an office so a lot of colleagues talk
about Trump but they're gonna talk about
the same things when things happen in
the news and a media so you have to
learn your point of view of like this is
what I feel about it this is my take on
it in my last special I was talking
about the national anthem and I'm you
know it was like this is this is my cake
this is how I process it you know so
I'll bring up something and then I'll
then I'll put it in another situation
that makes it sound ridiculous you know
so am I you know am i special I talk
about you know I think we should get rid
of the national anthem
you know because you can't just have a
ceremony whenever you want you know it's
like if you went to the supermarket and
church broke out so then I do an act out
because that's what I that's my thing I
love acting things out I love like and
by the way stand-up comedy is very much
acting you the audience is your scene
partner and you have to listen to them
like you get a vibe of like when they're
they don't find something funny or when
they're paying attention to you or when
they're or ma'am and you even get a vibe
sometimes when they don't like it so you
have to listen but anyway that's my
style so I'll bring up something sort of
serious I'll say how I feel about it
and then I'll and then I'll say why it
instead of explaining why I don't like
this because I'm not a wordsmith like
that I just put myself in this situation
that it'd be ridiculous
so I'll act it out like I'm in the
supermarket like price check on aisle 7
and then a reading from the book of John
according to you know and then you know
then you just had this funny visual of
me then I kneel down on the ground like
I'm doing the communion so you just get
this like I just I'm just painting a
picture that way so you have to find out
what your style is you know you know at
first when you do it you're gonna be a
little preachy I don't think that ever
goes away by the way when you first
think of something you want to be
preachy it's in your mind to it's crazy
like when you come up with a joke like
these thoughts are in your mind and you
know why it's funny because you're
processing in your mental computer see
you like what's funny because of boom
boom boom boom and you don't even
realize like a thousand things might be
going on in your head that make this
thing funny to you and then you go
onstage and you have to try to express
all of these thoughts in your head in
one sentence or
in a paragraph and that's the art of
stand-up comedy is expressing something
with visual words or being able to it
like being able to be someone that can
articulate things that people will
understand like this you just have to
find out what your style is but anyways
I don't even know this is helping but
I'm just on here talking about [ __ ] cuz
when you do a podcast you got to talk
about stuff but anyway I just remember
why is the joke funny to you this joke
is funny to you like so for me I think
this joke is funny to me because of this
that's your setup you're setting it up
in there and then what is this joke
about obviously you're gonna need to
express that clearly and then how do I
feel about this
that also is with within the joke and
then if you're a physical person you
might want to do you might do an act out
you know just like you're creating a
scene and then that's why people are
laughing because they now relate to that
more that to me is easier than these
people that have to use just words I
admire people that like they can set a
stage with just a sentence or two and
you're there that's a gift you know if
you're like an animated person like me
then you know you can unlike be up here
you know one of my most funniest jokes
to me I'm coming up was like I would be
like you know I have hairy knuckles you
know and then like I talked about going
to the Middle East and how people in the
Middle East are hairy you know and I
would be like you know people would
laugh and then I'd be like especially if
there's Middle Eastern people in the
crowd you know because I when I went to
the Middle East I was in the middle he's
doing this that's what was crazy I was
like oh you guys are hairy and then I'd
be like I don't know what the women are
laughing at you just as hairy you need a
razor this big and I would get to
microphone stand and be like and then I
would do a razor sound into the
microphone
and then I would act out like then I'm
shaving my eyebrows and shaving my Under
and I would put the mic down like I was
shaving my crotch and it just was one of
those things that like people just died
you know every single time cuz it's just
such a silly thing so sometimes you can
craft a joke or an active reason why I
like act outs because it's very much
like musically you can hear your
favorite song over and over and over
again
so what I love about act outs is that
you know even if people have heard the
joke they might sit here and be like oh
man he's gonna do that thing it's gonna
be so funny you know my buddy Bobby Lee
is like that Bobby is just such an
animated character on stage and his set
is like he doesn't he'll do the same set
like you know sometimes like for a year
and you're just sitting in a bank like I
can't believe I'm laughing at this again
but it's because of how he does it and
you believe him every time so that's
like the sign of someone that is a good
performer good entertainer and then
there's other people who like they just
can't say the same thing over and over
again and they're just so intellectual
that they have to like oh I have to do a
different set now or oh that was last
you know month and now I'm talking about
this and you know that's a gift too
you know it's just like I say there's no
right or wrong way so remember why is it
funny what are you talking about and I
guess my last tip is remember this try
to work backwards if you get stuck so a
lot of times you're writing something
you're like I don't know where to go so
if you have this thing that you know is
funny and you can figure out how to
explain it then you know what work back
and lead into it because then this
becomes maybe a better call back or it
becomes a tag or it becomes like you
know it just becomes like you know the
rule of threes are important you know
you talk about some of you do three
things you know this is this could be
one of the three now and now you you're
still in the same vein you're still in
the same subject I mean me personally I
like to stay on subject there's no right
or wrong way keep saying that but
sometimes you could stay on subject so
like if I'm talking about going to the
DMV then maybe my whole set right now
the ten minutes is gonna be my
experience of going to the DMV waiting
in line the eye test or the driving test
or you know the lady behind the
or yeah you know just whatever all the
let's say if you're talking abouts like
right now we're talking about stand-up
comedy if I all of a sudden start
talking about science it might be weird
so staying on subject is a way to keep
you you know to just to delve into your
point of view because if you talk about
the same thing more and more and more
and more you're gonna find yourself like
finding some nuggets but get some stage
time find out where the open mikes are
in your area they used to have a thing
called chuckle monkey when I was first
coming up I don't think it's a website
anymore but it was like a list of all of
the open mics I'm sure there's something
like that out there
maybe if I find something I'll put it in
the in the comments underneath the video
to figure out like where you can go to
do open mics but you should find out
wherever you are
you know wherever you are like find a
place there's always some cafe there's
always some place doing open mics and
just go up there and do it get past your
fear and just do it who cares if it's
funny or not or who cares if you don't
know what the hell you're doing because
this is you're not making money you just
this is just for you to learn and grow
so find that open mic get off your ass
don't be afraid just do it you know like
I said in the beginning I suggested you
take a class if you've never done it
before because it really is a
comfortable environment like when you it
feels good you're just in there with
other people and you know you guys are
commiserating you know you the fear you
have you get a peer group and then those
are the people that you're gonna start
going to open mics with too so I
remember I took a class when I first
started and my first performance was at
the Comedy Store and you know then you
know everything else is history after
that so you know find a class keep
writing
get off your ass get out there and
perform I if you if it doesn't work out
you know at least you try but those
people that are serious about it you got
to keep going and you can't stop you're
gonna have horrible sets you're gonna
have a horrible time you're gonna hate
the people there you're gonna fight with
other open lockers there's gonna be
people who are gonna tell you they oh
you stole my joke that's my joke people
always think they own subjects you know
but quick story I remember when I first
started long
this is my early before I quit then came
back Jurassic Park it was like a big
movie that's how long ago this was y'all
90 something you know and then I had
this joke about Jurassic Park like the
biggest movie of the year 300 million
dollars in the box office
so comics thing did they own the right
to talk about this movie that everybody
[ __ ] saw you know it doesn't make any
sense so what you know I had this joke
about like this is terrible by the way
but it was like oh it was like my mom
wasn't trying to hook me up with
somebody and I was saying it was a fat
girl and I knew she was coming because
you know it was a thanks key I remember
was a Thanksgiving joke so like I was
like the older girl I knew she was
coming because you know it was like I
would go boom you know like Jurassic
Park and I'd be like the cranberry sauce
was jiggling you know that whole the
even talking about it it's just stupid
but I had some other jokes about you
know and then like just comic k-much me
like yo man you do a macho brass like
Park jokes like [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself you know what I mean
like well somebody comes up to you about
something that is in the news or
something that is like not personal to
them and they acting like you taking
their joke tell him to go [ __ ] himself
okay cuz that pisses me off accusing
people of stealing is just as bad as
stealing if you don't have proof oh man
I remember I had some comic buddies they
all had this dumb joke about how hunting
is not a sport because the up because
the animals aren't playing there's so
many comics to do this joke about this
and they think they're so brilliant and
then they see somebody else doing it
near like yo man that's my hunting joke
you all should go [ __ ] yourself that's
how I feel about that you know it's like
you're not that I think you look online
and there's black and white footage of
comics doing the same joke I mean you
have to find your own take on it I mean
that's just what happens and there are
gonna be jokes that you just can't talk
about anymore a classic example is
airplane food so many comics were
traveling and traveling back in the 70s
80s and then everybody had an airplane
food joke then that just became one of
those things that yo do we don't comics
don't talk about airplane food anymore
another one like that as an example is a
what do you call it up oh the side
effects of medicine like you see a
commercial and they do the side effects
if you're doing a joke about that stop
just stop now okay cuz that's not funny
you know people gonna be like but we all
still have jokes like that like we think
that oh there's I want to be the first
person to have a take on this it's just
not I had this new joke even right now
where I'm talking about you know I want
self-driving cars cuz I don't want to
talk to the uber driver you know and in
fact that should be on the app don't
talk to me so that's not my job that's
how I do it
right and one of the waitresses at this
comedy club I go to at the Laugh Factory
Shelby she sent me a message
oh you're I'm so glad you're doing my
joke cuz she wrote on her Facebook as if
this chick thinks I'm looking at her
Facebook but anyway she's like oh I did
this joke and I was like damn like then
I thought of course just like it's
probably comics all over the freakin
country who's doing a I don't want the
uber driver to talk to me so you catch
yourself sometimes and you're like ah
man I thought it's just funny to you but
as long as you own it and just you know
just put it out with your own energy and
point of view and then you'll just move
on you know last tip is don't fall in
love with your material this is why
don't fall in love with it to the point
where you're out there like that's my
joke this is my joke a lot of new comics
act like that you're when you're a new
comic you're gonna be like you're gonna
think these words are so precious and
just remember the words and the jokes
are not what make you you make you
you're the one that makes this funny
you're the one people are gonna want to
see so don't make excuses you hear
somebody doing it y'all man okay very
very last story I used to have this joke
about Jesus on the cross you know cuz I
would be like you know Jesus is about
Jesus being in shape you know then I'll
be like he's up there showing off and I
would do like this you know and then
like I saw this some of the other people
had these jokes about
Jesus has six-pack abs and this and that
and then people come to you like they
think that's so original and they come
at you like yo man that's my joke that's
kind of my joke and you're just like I
said Paul in the beginning I was like
are you kidding me
you mean you think you own Jesus that's
what you're telling me right now you
think talking about Jesus you have the
you've cornered the market on talking
about Jesus so then you know what she do
as yet I became an older comic I knew
that okay got a move on from that
okay last last last last story as an
example
am i special I have a joke about you
know how it's right but it's not as
racist as we think it is you know cuz
when you go to soccer matches and go to
soccer matches in Europe and they're
throwing bananas at black players and
then I say
if one banana hit LeBron James you know
and then I go on to say and it
originally ever going to joke and say
like you know I wouldn't make the
reference to banana gate that's how I
said it in reference to what I was
talking about and then Chappelle comes
out with a special and he has a whole
thing about banana gate in his special
his own thing so then I have people
coming up to me like the morning the
managers at the at the Comedy Store he
came up to me said yo Erica you know
Chappelle special just came out and he
you know but you can't you know banana
gay so you know I didn't know he was
doing that I didn't see it before he saw
it I know I was doing it but like that's
how it goes somebody more famous than
you or even not more famous don't even
matter if they're famous or not but
somebody that gigantic if they go on and
do a special and they say something and
and you have a similar joke guess what
guys
it ain't your joke anymore and then you
move the [ __ ] on don't follow and I know
how easy it is to fall in love with your
material [ __ ] you just like you love
doing it but trust yourself that you
were gonna find other things to talk
about and you're gonna bring that stank
to it find out what your comedy stank is
and put it on everything that you say
but anyways y'all thank you for
listening to Griffin with Griffin this
is episode eight next week oh man I got
a special episode coming next week it's
my first ever guest and we're gonna be
at a new location I'm still gonna be
doing stuff here but this is gonna be at
a special location that's what I'm gonna
be doing my guests I don't know actually
might have guests come here too but
looking for next week for a special
episode but anyway this has been riffing
with Griffin and I really appreciate
everybody that's listening I love your
comments and if you still got theme
songs for me send them out and I
appreciate you thanks a lot